[Musique]
il était une fois les murs sologne
donnant fuselier à lamotte beuvron le
public répond toujours présent il y a
ceux qui découvrent et voyagent léger et
les autres les fidèles qui ont tout
prévu
on a l'habitude on le soir après à
l'humidité donc c'est une vraie
organisation pour faire les sandwichs
pour avoir les jeux pour patienter
passer une bonne soirée un bon spectacle
vêtements chauds oreiller et uv à
proximité certains profitent d'une belle
fin de journée l'ambiance monte
la fête va bientôt commencer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
8ce lognes 6 tonnes d'artifices sur une
façade de 300 m un grand et beau
spectacle pyrotechnique apprécié comme
il se doit même pas froid
les nuits sont fraîches à lamotte
beuvron donc le duvet était
indispensable pour cacher les petits
pieds pas avoir froid aux petits petons
serait difficile après une partie compte
consacrer à pinocchio un concert de
lumière envahi le ciel loir et chérien
parfois c'est loin mais c'est beau
ça ne fait presque une heure mais on
vient quand même moi j'aime bien mes
lumières qui fait pas super super
pierrette affrontées c'était super
[Musique]
pour une grande première au parc
équestre fédéral c'est pari gagné
fait au moins dix ans je fais et là j'ai
trouvé le nouveau cycle super chouette
c'est vraiment splendide c'est vraiment
à voir et je suis je suis ah oui bravo
ça fait du bien parce que surtout le
remerciement vis-à-vis des bénévoles
sans qui rien n'aurait été possible
pascal andré et toute son équipe de
l'association les nuits de sologne nous
donne maintenant rendez-vous en 2019
avec carmen
[Musique]